- On a 50 % des microbrasseries
qui ont moins de 5 ans.
Donc, la croissance, elle est
vraiment plus soutenue depuis
les dernières années.
- Un marché en pleine
effervescence qui a attiré
ces deux amies originaires
du Brésil. Elles ont un bar
à Rio de Janeiro, mais c'est en
Montérégie qu'elles ont ouvert
leur propre usine de brassage
l'an dernier.
TATIANA FULTON, copropriétaire,
- C'est à St-Jean-sur-Richelieu
et maintenant, notre capacité
de production, c'est environ
15 000 litres par mois et on
a distribué partout au Québec
et dans envrion 900 points
de vente.
- C'est donc avec une industrie
qui a le vent dans les voiles
que s'ouvre le 27e Mondial
de la Bière. Selon la fondatrice
de l'événement, l'engouement
pour la consommation locale
explique en partie la popularité
des produits de microbrasserie.
JEANNINE MAROIS, fondatrice et
présidente, Mondial de la bière
- Ça fait partie de la culture
de vie des gens. C'est de la
qualité de vie de boire de la
bonne bière, et de l'intégrer
dans notre quotidien.
- Qu'on se rende compte
qu'au Québec, qu'on est très
versatiles. On va avoir des
styles anglais, des styles
allemands, des styles belges,
des styles québécois aussi, donc
on va brasser un peu toutes
sortes de bières et on va
surtout bien le faire.
- Qualité, créativité.... c'est
grâce à leur travail acharné que
les brasseurs du Québec sont en
mesure